[Music]
hey guys gq's jake wolfe here and it
seems like every guy this season is
looking to pick up a bomber jacket but
here are five easy things you need to
know before buying one for yourself
all right tip number one and this is a
tip whether we're talking suits shirts
t-shirts sweaters whatever and that's
fit we think that when you're buying a
bomber jacket
it should fit the way that a great suit
fits it should fit snug in the shoulder
slim through the sleeves slim through
the body and really just look
modern and tailored as opposed to
something that is big and bulky like you
might have seen in the past
tip number two and this is just a little
detail you can look for when you're
shopping for a bomber jacket
that's hardware zippers you might think
that they're a dime a dozen but actually
looking at the zippers can tell you a
lot about the jacket
as you can see here these silver zippers
here are from company called riri
and they're really known for making
really great zippers and you know that
when you see their name they're gonna
get something that's really high quality
all right guys tip number three and this
is just a little styling detail that's
something we like to call the reverse
stance as you can see here i've got this
little button at the top of my bomber
jacket
while mine has a button there are a lot
of jackets out there that actually have
two-way zippers
you can zip it from the bottom up or
just like a cooler modern
look that we've seen a lot of people
wearing we think looks really great all
right tip number four and this is about
dressing up your bomber jacket keep
everything really monochromatic you know
i have a gray sweater i have a white
shirt i have a darker gray tie
you actually let the green color in your
bomber jacket really shine alright tip
number five
as you can see it did a little outfit
change and one of our favorite looks for
fall is wearing the hoodie
underneath the bomber jacket of course
it's important that the hoodie that i'm
wearing is not too
thick otherwise the slim sleeves in the
bomber jacket would start to feel like
suffocating a little bit and really this
is again just letting the bomber jacket
do the talking for you it'll really
set you off as a really stylish guy for
fall and it's a look that you can wear
all season long
all right guys so those are five things
you need to know before buying a bomber
jacket
go out go online hit some stores pick
one up for yourself